hello everyone and welcome back to the
Women's World Chess Championship between
Alexandra Gordon and did you win jin-joo
engine being the defending world
champion this is the second part of the
match the first six games played in
Shanghai China ended in in in well in
the draw basically four games were drawn
one game went to Jew and one game to
Korea China and now they are in
volleyball so the first game their a
game seven ended in a draw and this is
game eight so it's a really exciting
game I'm sure you're gonna enjoy it so
let's dive straight into it see for
Nigeria chicken on the English opening
is on the board we have e six sorry
about that
Knight to c3 we have D five and now the
four transposing into the Queens gambit
declined with Knight to f6 Knight to f6
a trade in the center C captures ECAP
Tristan Bishop to g5 now c6 and now
strengthen in the center as one of the
defenders is now paying the we have III
preparing to develop the light square
bishop and h6 asking what do you want to
do with the bishop do you want to trade
or do you want to go back with Bishop to
h4 and now Bishop to e7 Bishop to d3
good HP no continuous development and
now Knight to e4 here offering a lot of
traits as something you or often want to
do when playing black in such positions
you want to trade down and remove some
of the pressure and here Bishop captures
on e7 is pretty much an automatic and
pretty much everyone plays it here but
good actually goes for Bush of the g3
and it's a move that has been played
only two times in this position both
times in 2012 for some reason and in
both games that white achieved a victory
so definitely a good idea to try and
surprise you in June in such an
important event so here in those games
the bishop the FI was played on both
occasions but here we have night
Catherine g3 and it is as of move nine
that we have a completely new game which
is not very often the case I mean in
move nine a completely new game in the
Queens gambit the client if you think
about it okay H capture some g3 in town
tonight to d7 REE maneuvering the other
Knight to f6 we have Knight to f3 and
the knife to F
6.now Queen to c2 preparing the Castle
queenside Bishop to e6 and mal castling
queenside and although this might might
not be the most precise way the three
disposition but it is the most ambitious
way you double your G points you have
the same you open G file for your rook
you're asking black how do you want to
play this game do you want to Castle
King side and maybe allow me to start
attacking you do want to Castle
queenside what kind of game is this
going to be so uh we have Queen to c7
now still leaving both options on the
table Kings the b1 a nice prophylactic
move getting rid of looking from the C
file at some point you know c5 might be
played opening up the C file so you do
not want your king and queen on the same
file we have queenside castle by Jew and
Knight to a4 now of course you want to
bring your knight to the c5 it will be
an excellent outpost for the knight and
the black will either have to endure the
night being there or trade one of the
bishops for it so kink the b8 also a
nice prophylactic move and now Knight
the c5 Bishop captures the knight is too
too strong a piece to remain there and
now D captures on c5 if you do Queen
captures and c5 we allow this Knight to
e4 move which is not something you want
to all-out black and even if you retreat
the c2 because Knight captures on f2 is
also an idea so Queen c2 now you just
guard the pawn with rook h2 e8 and you
cannot win the pawn duty to do to attack
the characters captures and Bishop
captures it with check you lose the
Queen so instead of Queen captures we
have D captures on c5 and now Bishop to
g4 a very nice pin and of course you can
react and immediately it gets out of it
we have rook to c1 so now the Queen can
move as the rook will also be guarding
the c5 pawn bishop captures an f3 g
captures and now the freeing d4 move
offering a trade on d4 and also freeing
up the the d5 square for the black
knight seborrhea Gina of course does not
want the night to land on d5 and pretty
much as of this point you will see that
the whites entire strategy is just
controlling the knight on f6
it's gonna be really awesome so with g5
now not allowing it for and here garage
Tina again prepares to push f4 Quinta b2
we have Knight to d7 and now just f4 of
course not allowing the knight to land
on e5 so f4 and here we have f6 by but
you G captures captures and h5 would
have been interesting because you
already have a nice past a h1 which you
can start pushing down the board but
like I said f6 was played and then
outcomes well feel free to pause the
video and try and figure out the best
way to go about the position while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations and finding the Dean
nicest way to treat disposition now
there are well ok you can either start
by playing b4 b4 is a move you will play
in any variation as you cannot leave the
c5 pawn unattended so you can either
start by before or you can play the move
but you're actually in a plate which is
rook to h5 before will be played at some
point so there's no need to rush it
point is you want to bring the other
rook to h1 and you want to go after the
h6 bone so this is what happens G
captures on h4
on f/4g captors on f4 and now again look
at this Knight the night has nowhere to
go you can't go here you can go here you
can go here you can go to f8 which is
what I do in June place she wants to
bring the Queen into the game and also
maybe riemann over the night the e6 or
g6 but goralina again blocks the the
squares of the night f5 so now Queen
back to g7 okay now the e5 square has
been vacated so maybe retreating with
the Knight to d7 and then the e5 is the
way to go but not wanting to over over
use the knight first Queen to g7 maybe
with ideas of now bringing the night
here maybe rook here and then maybe
jumping out with the Queen however Queen
to f4 with check first king that a 8 and
now Queen to H 2 again putting pressure
on D and E h6 pawn with nice to b7 now
going after the e5 square but now f4
again
this night is not having the greatest
day and here and well an active idea
seems to be something like this is what
I thought about Rudy 2g8 maybe just you
know crash down with a queen however
it's not enough white will always play
before like we mentioned you keep an eye
on this point here and now if you go
down with the Queen
yes it's an active move but captures
captures and now you play Bishop to c4
this is the White Star move preventing
black from doubling
rooks here well not at the moment here
you can't leave your H point hanging but
it's just a just a very strong strong
piece here and next you're just gonna
you're just gonna improve your position
rook rook is coming here gonna pick up
this pawn this is a weak weak bone this
is a weak point and it's just uh well
it's just a very strong position for
white it could be playable for black
however you know it's definitely not
pleasant
so instead Queen to f8 piling up on this
e5 pawn and now the b4 move so although
you could have played it then it's
better to play it now when your opponent
asks you to play this is not always the
case you have to be careful b6 now now
piling up on the pawn here and here
'if i preparing east six and here
although you could play captures
captures and give why the two connected
passed points and this is in fact
something the engine prefers as a human
you know that you are going to lose this
position so again it's one of those
positions where the strongest move
simply isn't enough so here gieux tries
to complicate things with bc v capturing
the pawn this way perhaps trying to
trying to get something like you know
white's the plate east six but even if
you do there there are a lot of very
very good ideas for black for example c4
opening up an attack towards the b4 pawn
and now after you capture on c4 Knight
b6 going after the knight but you can
always play rook to c5 again preventing
blacks on capturing and it's just a
crazy position so it does make sense for
Julian to try and complicate with be c5
as there there are a lot of ideas here
however we're edge cannot does not go
for the seemingly excellent east six but
right
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the move she played again while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those who are able to do it
congratulations on supporting this
beautiful diagonal here and for those
who just want to enjoy the show
Queen g2 or Quinta h1 is possible Queen
each one was played in the game and now
Queen captures and c6 is being
threatened so nice to be 8 defending it
and now again you bring more attackers
towards the c6 pawn b5 is definitely an
option it does make sense however
coriaci owner goes for Bishop to e4
bringing a more attackers this way rub
the h7 now after all the trades you can
always bring the rook to g7 which is
which will be useful as the King isn't
be one but rook captures and c5
Nagarajan brings a third attacker to the
c6 pawn we have cooked the b7 now
preparing the capture here but now we
just pinned the rook Bishop captures on
c6 and Knight captures and Queen
captures on c6 and again again you have
to decide what you do here King to be a
ton pinning seems to be a good way but
it's still very hard to play a six and
now even if you capture here just came
to a 1 black doesn't have a good
follow-up and if Queen to g7 if you want
to try and checkmate checkmate white it
doesn't really work because of rugby 5
check now rook captures Queen captures
with check King 8 and now Queen to c6
check and now you have to trade Queens
and go into a lost endgame with black
because if you don't if you go King b8
then just look the h1 prevents the Queen
delivering checks and the rook the b1
it's game over there's no defense
against rugby 1 so although again King
b8 is the engine stop recommendation it
is once again not not enough to play the
best move so Jew tries an active
approach d3 you have a passed pawn why
not push it
rook the b5 now threatening mate so rock
the BA defending and now e 6 and now
creating a very strong passed pawn Queen
to d8 now supporting the push of the
pawn here and now look back to h1 you
will have nice control of the d1 square
we have d2 and now of course you don't
want to
guard the b1 square with something like
King to c2 then rook c8 it just wins the
game because you blunder your queen
so rook to d5 this is how you block the
pond we have Queen to c8 and now only
now garage penetrates Queen captures we
have rook captures and b4 first a nice
in-between move that picks up a pawn
before we grabbing the Queen King to a-1
and now rook captures Queen on c8 and
now rook captures and d2 and now we have
this endgame where white black white has
four points black has three but there's
also the problem of the past ecigs pawn
now if you capture in just each seven
wins the game there's no stopping rook
the rook to the d8 so we have king to b7
black stars bring in a king in third
game which okay is something that white
for the moment is unable to do but rook
the d7 checked with King Tubby 6 and now
East 7 again threatening to just win the
game straight away with rook to b8 so
rook to e8 and now for the last time in
this video feel free to pause the game
video and try to find the winning move
for white while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations this is
rook in games 101 this is you have to
know this even if someone wakes you up
abruptly you know in in 4 a.m. and asks
you what does white play here and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's rock to e1 it I know it's just
putting the rug behind the past pawn but
it's protecting this pawn and again
threatening rook to d8 so there's no
defense against this whatever you play
any move black plays doesn't really
matter just look here you're either
winning grabbing a queen or or winning a
rook and if you try something else I
don't know what else is there to try you
could try rook c4 and after or d8 the
block this way now okay
you cannot capture but now you can
capture here captures and now you just
bring another queen into the game
captures captures and you are now you
know again in a young gustafson end game
where one player has a rook and the
other player doesn't so that's the game
I hope you enjoyed it after rook e1 you
in June resigned and the garag Gina
takes the lead for the first time in
this Women's World Chess Championship
match she is now up one point and there
are still four more games to be played
so it's going to be
interesting will we have a new Women's
World Chess Champion or will jus in June
bounce back we'll see so once again I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank D Sheng ken Thompson
Christopher Gordon Frank Holmes and
Salvatore John Burnett for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Women's World Chess Championship the
Tata Steel checking up in your wonderful
suggestions and when there's a you know
a gap in between events continuing the
Morphy saga of course so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your Saturday